okay I'm very happy to give the first
speech on this day I hope you're all
awake I can't even see you we curse it
so so much light in my face here anyway
this will also be easy I guess for
waking up it's not horribly technical
it's more like philosophical or even
psychological I would say it has two of
the new things I guess in this
conference go and DevOps so I thought I
could connect both of them let's see if
that works out let's start with my
street cred I used to work for this
company called Google you might heard
about them you might also know that they
created go the programming language I
worked for them for seven and a half
years and disclaimer is I have never
written go code in production at Google
I actually have never written a real go
program while I was there which is
actually part of the story I will tell
you later in this talk what I have
learned though while I was at Google is
I kind of peeked into the hive mind of
Google I kind of understood how they
roll when they develop things when they
operate and that will also play a role
in this talk
this was my next station SoundCloud
SoundCloud hits everywhere this is my
current employer I've been there for
five years by now so it's also quite a
while to reiterate on those words in the
title if I'm asked if SoundCloud is to
never ops I usually tell them oh yeah
we're doing their force we are even
doing two DevOps there's a bit of a
story behind that which is not the story
in this talk but I would say we are
pretty cool there Forbes company and we
are also a company that is doing micro
services I'm
sure that I remember correctly the
Wikipedia page for microservices hard
listed SoundCloud as one of the early
adaptors poster Charles for micro
services I checked it because I wanted
to put a screenshot there on the slide
it's gone I mean that's Wikipedia I
could have reared it or something but
okay anyway we were pretty early in the
game when it came to micro service
migration so another word from the
travel and to complete it
we were also pretty early adapters of go
we were even considered a go shop back
then I'm not sure if that was ever true
I would not say that nowadays SoundCloud
is a go shop it's more a scholarship the
reason why that has happened will also
be follow this talk but when I started
at SoundCloud five years ago I had to
start a project this is what we do right
you you you join the company and then
you help somebody else in their project
to get into how the company works and
that person I worked with was Peter
Bergen if you're a cofán a happy gopher
then you might know Peter he is pretty
active in the community he gives a lot
of really nice talks and he was also
there early on back then he was at
SoundCloud and he wrote a micro service
and go and I joined him in that effort
so totally micro services go there from
everything there but yeah nowadays we
are not writing a lot of micro services
and go and Peter's also know that sounds
loud anymore
which again will be a bit a part of the
topic of this talk my final street cred
proof is this one it's also here on my
laptop you might know I hope you know
what what that stands for that's the
Prometheus logo promises a metric space
monitoring and alerting system which I
have been busy with for quite some time
this is totally a DevOps tool people
always ask me is Prometheus the DevOps
tool and then I think and yeah I don't
know what's the DevOps tool but for me
Prometheus totally is a DevOps tool
Prometheus is especially suited to
monitor micro services there we are and
it's written and go so perfect match for
the topic of this talk but let's not
just do my own stuff let's do science
let's go to github github thankfully
tells you what language a repository is
written in and then there's a totally
scientific measure of popularity which
is github stars the most important
currency in the open source world so you
can search for repos that are written go
and you can sort it by number of github
stars and then you get a list I just
picked the top 14 because they fit onto
slides but yeah it's all very scientific
as you can see the first one the most
popular repository indeed have written
go is Moby which is something something
container I mean I'm not going into all
the details here we just want to find
out what areas those repositories like
what areas do they cover and if it's
about containers it's totally DevOps
right I mean that's a fallacy you can do
there forces out containers or you can
do containers and totally not do DevOps
but for simplicity let's assume
obviously DevOps tool just actually yeah
the second one here is the language
itself it's also hosted on github so
that doesn't really count as I get a go
project if it's the language itself so
let's not not look at that the third one
is kubernetes it's also here in my
laptop
that's a hope everything changed
oh cool
coronaries that's a container
orchestration framework you might or
hopefully you know about it it's even
more popular than Prometheus and it's
written go obviously and it's totally
DevOps right containers scheduling
orchestration up there lantern that
looks Chinese to me you might not have
heard about it and if you haven't heard
about it it's because you're living in a
free country this is a tool to
circumvent the big firewall so hopefully
we will never need that but it's written
in go and that's kind of networking web
browsing right so it's a bit different
the next one awesome go it's just a
curated list of links to other projects
and libraries and frameworks and go so
that doesn't really count but tells you
how popular this Hugo that's a static
site generator which is almost front-end
right like you can it's a go program to
generate websites static web sites so
even there it plays a role let's walk to
the other side what do we have here
GOx or whatever that is that's a get
hosted github something so source
control dev tool pervs even DevOps the
next one it's again this one is a ebook
about writing for app applications Wisco
doesn't really count as a go program but
since there's a very popular ebook about
writing web applications let's go I
guess you can write web applications
with go same thing is a file
synchronization tool again networking
Djinn is an HTTP router which is like
good for writing web applications but
also good for writing micro services
should they use HTTP which many of them
do um and we're almost there
there go a theorem the b-word blockchain
must be everywhere I think if you write
a go client for some blockchain thing
doesn't tell us a lot about go it's just
a very hot thing at CD that's the key
value store at the basis of its the kind
of backing key value store for
kubernetes can also be used on its own
totally a DevOps tool
Prometheus I think I talked about it
right there this again and caddy is an
HTTP to web server so we see a lot of
things that are clearly DevOps tools for
whatever her definition you use but I
think it's pretty clear it's networking
web serving even like from any things
and a bit of micro services web apps so
kind of makes sense this is what as goes
useful mostly like let's say systems
programming we can only I mean get up
stars are not so scientific at all
so let's look what the industry is doing
and a very hot and hipster industry
foundation Istiqlal native computing
foundation that's the sub formation of
the Linux Foundation and it's
essentially all the cloud providers
everybody who has some say in the
industry isn't this foundation it has
been founded as the home of kubernetes
essentially so when Google Google also
created kubernetes I might not have
mentioned that they wanted kubernetes to
not be a Google thing they wanted it to
be owned for some vendor neutral entity
so they could have just handed it over
to an existing foundation or they could
have founded in foundation of their own
just for kubernetes the kubernetes
foundation what they actually did was
something in the middle
they created a sub foundation of the
Linux donation which is like not quite a
new one and they said this should not
just be for kubernetes this should be
for a set of tools that we need in the
modern day the world and they call the
clone native computing foundation they
donated kubernetes the cloud native
computing foundation is hosting many
projects they have a three tier entry
procedure
you're either sandboxing or you are
incubating or you're graduated there are
two graduated projects and now you can
probably already named them kubernetes
and promises they are both written in go
now let's look at all the incubating
projects I won't go into all of them in
detail but I have to watch this here
together with you
let's check this container DS written
and go rocket is written and go see a
nice written ego Yeager's written and go
even as the girlfriend its logo not a
razor and go V tensor tango Cardenas
wouldn't go and a chance this wouldn't
go helmets wouldn't go rook is written
and go so there we are
it's almost everything written ago there
are projects that are not written and go
fluent e is Rui this is C plus for us I
think yeah
Anwar is C plus for us and linka D is
scholar all the other three projects are
not really written in any language
they're more like standards or API
definitions like G RPC is remote
procedure calls you can do in any
language right it's not that you can say
G obviously is written and go so of all
the projects that are written in a
particular language most of them an
overwhelming majority in of like CNCs
projects are written and go now you
could say this is the leading industry
foundation in the field everything is
written ago almost so we can stop here
right like go is the way to go in the
cloud native world which is kind of has
a huge over-leveraged DevOps done right
we just follow the crowd but no you
should not do that like you should think
you should play devil's advocate so
let's play devil's advocate this is
about distributed file storage there was
a time where people wrote distributed
file storage in Java
Hadoop right comes to mind I don't know
why that was considered a good match I
whatever I mean I think Java was just
super popular back then it was the
dominant language that everybody knows
knew and you still had a platform issue
right you wanted to distribute those
programs everywhere and there was a
platform diversity out there nowadays
for better or worse that
been solved there's essentially one
platform the internet runs on which is
containers on Linux so kind of the JVM
is more like overhead but anyway they
wrote distributed file systems in Java
but I'm not talking about Hadoop now I'm
talking about extreme FS if you have
never heard about it don't blame
yourself
it's an open source project even had a
EU funding was very academic but never
really like took off as a popular
network file system distributed file
system for reasons not to be discussed
here but some of the people in the
initial team who whatever wrote their
PhD thesis about it and everything they
thought if this is not working as an
open source project but we know it's
good stuff let's found a company and
create an commercial enterprise version
on top of that that company is called
quo bite and if you look at their job
description they're not hiring go
developers they are hiring Java and C++
developers so you can assume they are
probably rewriting some of this in non
Java but the language does not go as we
might have assumed from the previous
slide the languages C++ so why I
actually asked them and they looked at
me when I asked like why aren't you
using this hipster go thing and they
looked at me blankly and said how could
that ever work like there's garbage
collection the the garbage collector
kicks in at some point and stops the
world actually back then this is a few
years ago go but garbage collection was
really problematic
it had like multi tens or hundreds of
milliseconds stop the world garbage
collection if you are working in and
like millisecond latency or sub
millisecond latency requirement then you
can't do that right and also the
scheduler like they looked at me and
said I cannot control the scheduler like
the routines are scheduled maybe perhaps
at some point so it's actually you don't
have a lot of control of those things
you need for something like a file
system
so yeah not not a perfect fit perfectly
could use rust these days which avoids
the problem of garbage collection by not
having average collection also what's
the been benefits of course but yeah
let's look at something that is actually
written in go the docker for some reason
it didn't make it in the top 14 most
popular repositories on github but it's
immensely popular right docker made
containers popular containers existed
before docker SoundCloud was using
containers before docker Google was
using containers long before docker you
could argue that kind of invented
containers for Linux or at least pushed
the development because they needed it
long ago but like docker made a popular
Dockers written go
so for managing containers perhaps go is
the right choice
if you ever see KC he used to work for
Korres which then became redhead and now
kind of became IBM's all of a sudden he
gave this talk at one of the go meters
in Berlin I haven't found a recording a
perv see is giving the truck somewhere
else and you can see it or you find a
recording but there are slides later the
slides will all be there available for
you on the website so you can just click
on this link and at least you will get
the slide deck which has little tell you
lot about this talk this is mind-blowing
Casey explains how the go scheduler
works how go maps go routines to actual
OS threats and this is all super
sophisticated and super nice as and you
can use those lightweight go routines
instead of heavyweight OS turrets but
unfortunately there's UNIX and POSIX and
a lot of things that are important for
container management like kernel names
phrases and capabilities and user IDs
they are all bound to OS for it so if
you manage all of this in your go
program you might just manage one of the
OS florets and then
time you do something you're gonna team
works on another OS threat and it's all
quite problematic there's some lock our
store thing in the ego standard library
which has become increasingly useful
with later go releases but to really do
this you need C go what a see go see go
is to use like C together with go and go
has a collection of Proverbs you can
Google go proverbs yet then you will
find a web page where they have all
those proverbs and none of the programs
is C go is not gold which is true like
proverbs are supposed to be true so if
you you see go you are actually not
using go and so ironically for docker to
do what docker does it needs sea right
so go was perhaps not the optimal choice
I don't know to see how crazy this is
this is not from the docker codebase
it's from open containers but it's a
little go package that allows you to do
those namespace manipulation and you can
see this year if you read the first
sentence the NS enter package which is
just a special any constructor that is
called before the go runtime has a
chance to boot this makes me dizzy
already and if you read on it's like
yeah
mind-blowing if you ever see something
like this in your go code this is C code
in your go code and it's run at specific
locations it's like all where you think
this language was clearly not meant to
do this what it's doing here yeah okay
third point playing devil's advocate
memory management there's an old bug in
the go repo the one the second most
popular repo and go which is the
language itself which asks for
mechanisms for monitoring heap size
because that's something that many
programs need many programs need the
memory they need and if they can't get
it it's fine to crash like go just
panics if it's out of memory
but other programs they want to take the
memory they need and then they want to
take as much memory on top of that as
possible to do a better job caching
comes to mind those programs don't want
to they want just to take the memory
that they still have available without
looming and that's really hard and go
ironically not ironically fittingly the
one I mean nameless I'm an example in
this issue it's very long you can read
it up you can find it after the talk
there was Prometheus quoted as an
example for programs that actually needs
that and I clarified this a bit so if
you want to blow your mind again you can
follow all those links where I linked
into the Prometheus codebase to show you
how Prometheus manages the memory
despite using go and it's not pretty
it's really like weird now the irony
comes now the ironies that Prometheus
this is from it is one campaign promises
to doesn't need that anymore because
there is now much better way of cashing
reuse and mapping which asked the
operating system to do the caching force
but still there are a lot of programs
who need that and even a mapping is not
really first class citizen in goal like
you need to take the real raw sis call
to MF something and then there is
another go proverb that and map always
sorry sis calls always have to be
guarded by build tags which means you
need platform-specific code you need
different code for unix
and for windows and perhaps even for
different flavors of unix in the MF case
that works rather well like it's just a
tiny bit of code that is platform
dependent but you still notice go was
never meant to do those things so why
why are all those hipster cloud native
systems DevOps whatever tools using go
if it's such a bad systems language
I have ideas why they use that but I'll
I'll come to that later let's first try
the other thing if go sucks for systems
programming perhaps it works for micro
services and for your actual product
there were a few repos in our scientific
survey so let's let's look at that going
micro services is definitely a thing I
just stumbled upon a 15 part blog post
series by Oracle partner about writing
micro services and go and I mean it will
haunt you I think I stumbled upon this
because the part 15 is about monitoring
your micro services with Prometheus but
anyway this is not about promises and
promises being written ago this is about
the micro servers you monitor being
written in go and so there's totally a
community doing that if you like if you
just Google go micro services the first
set is actually go kid and now another
circle is complete go kid was created by
Peter Bergen my mentor in my staffing
project at Sound Cloud and this was also
created at about the time where Peter
left SoundCloud so there's a bit of
correlation so this is a kid to allow
you to write micro service and go in a
really nice way and it's also fairly
popular it's not one of the top 14
popular go Reapers that Gator but it's
fairly popular so you should be able to
write micro services so now let's look
at SoundCloud just for a second and
think about the story of go at
SoundCloud so saga definitely loves all
those clown native tools we use
kubernetes we had a container
orchestration thing before kubernetes
homegrown it's a bit of an adventure but
it was also written go we all like we
kind of created prometheus which is
written in go so yeah we are definitely
familiar with that and we also still
using go a lot in the infrastructure
area but we are not using it a lot for
micro services so how did that happen
when we start with microservices we fell
into that common trap of thinking oh
great now we have like microservices
that means every team can do their own
thing right they write their own service
so every team can pick the tool they
like best the language they like this
and we have this Cambrian explosion
sorry animations with Google slides but
anyway a camera an explosion of tools
and languages at SoundCloud I joked we
had more languages than engineers which
was probably not true but it was an
approximation and some people use go
some people use closure some people use
Haskell and you can come up with any
hits the language you want and we will
probably have a micro service in that
language
our Sean Treadway is our principal
engineer he called that optimizing for
individual productivity which sounds
good but it's actually not good because
you want to be productive as an
organization and that was not optimizing
for productivity as an organization
because what happens in the real life
people come and go they leave the
company you hire new people or you have
people moving around within the company
that's that's a good thing that's agile
like lower case a agile and micro
services are micro because they are also
like easy to move around I can say ok
this team now owns this other micro
service and if there's two people who
really liked Haskell and wrote a bunch
of micro services in Haskell leave the
company because they want to work for a
hundred percent Haskell company or
something then all of a sudden somebody
else inherits the ownership of that
micro service and they now have to learn
Haskell I mean it's not a bad thing to
learn Haskell it's probably good to
learn Haskell
but you wanted to write a new micro
service or you want to fix about but now
first you have to learn a new language
and perhaps the language that will teach
you a lot but it's difficult to learn so
at some point we realized ok we have to
convert
on something and we also realized that
we need to reduce the constant costs per
micro service because that's another
thing for micro service to work it must
be easy to create a new one and there is
always a constant cost like everybody
has to implement a circuit breaker or
something it's some of this is
complicated and people have to reinvent
the wheel all the time if they all use
their own tooling and so you you want to
share a bit like this chair nothing
approaches purpose not so good after all
so we created some framework and we also
build on top of what others did and our
choice was finagle back then Twitter's
finagle stack which is written in Scala
so you're ideally writing your micro
services in Scala as well at least you
were bound to the JVM and what happened
then this was 2015 it's kind of the year
of go kid and the Year Peter left and
it's all happening back then phil
created this slide phil Calzado you
might know him because he talked a lot
about our micro service migration
he was like leading that more or less
back then and he wrote this infamous
slide internally building in Scala
should be a no-brainer sure because
we're using C Nagel building in other
jvm languages should be easy that's easy
because you can still use all the
tooling and like we build some stuff on
top of vinegar we called it JVM kid so
it was very easy to create micro service
building and something else should still
be possible right this is kind of the
liberal approach here or you said oh
great I can still write my micro
services and go if I really wanted to
which is still happening like if you
have a good reason for that and this
might be performance certain behaviors
that Virgo might be better than the JVM
or something this is still happening but
all the go fans
we're looking at the slide and saying ok
now we are kind of third class citizen
in this new world order mmm that didn't
make everybody happy but it kind of
makes sense in its own way right because
if we wanted some convergence you just
didn't converge on go
um so now some people said this was just
happening because there was no finagle
for go finagle Ross Scholar / DVM and
you could say go kid is finagle of go
and I mean I don't know it's if it's on
the webpage but Peter had a few initial
talks about Cokie where he essentially
said this was kind of a tragedy go lost
the microservice medal at sound Club
because there was no finagle so we
should have seen a girl for go and
create a go kid I mean broadly
simplified anyway now everybody could
just go and no pun intended go and
create microservice and go it's it's
happening I'm my view might be biased
because I go to all the Gopher meters
but not through the scala meters so I
see all the companies really using go
mostly and not studying so much the
scholar companies except my own one but
yeah it's totally possible to do that
of course SoundCloud is not going to
rewrite everything go now because we
have our tooling we have our existing
micro service it works sufficiently well
and also a very powerful language like
scholar has certain advantages like it's
very expressive it's kind of what I call
a multi-paradigm language whatever
programming paradigm you want you can do
it probably in scala in a very elegant
way well I'll go it's kind of the super
primitive thing were yeah I don't know I
call it a no paradigm language we will
later see if this is actually a
disadvantage or perhaps not do you
understand why go it's the way it is we
should this is the psychology partner we
should go back to Go's childhood at
Google and understand the parents and
the upbringing and then we will do a bit
of psychoanalysis and will understand
why eco is the way it is so Google had
this weird idea that you should only use
three languages
it's actually makes a lot of sense again
from a certain perspective it's kind of
the opposite of our Cambrian explosion
the they used Java Python and C++ C++
and Java being just industry leaders
back then Python when Google adopted it
it was fairly exotic but now it's also
one of the dominant languages of our
profession so that also kind of makes
sense but I think they didn't pick those
because they were so popular or it
played a role but they wanted to cover
certain areas and they didn't want loads
of many different languages they are
adamant about it like if they acquire in
your company like one day totally
integrate their code face into into
their own code base and it's a Haskell
code base and it's super ingenious code
eventually they'll all be rewritten in
C++ or something they they of course do
use other languages like you cannot
write iOS apps without objective-c and
you use JavaScript to run in the browser
but they are all kind of special-purpose
domain-specific for general-purpose
coding if that's a word they use those
three they used to use those three
languages and then there were so many
attempts of fans of a certain language
to tell to teach the Google - to
convince the Google hivemind that this
fourth language is totally required and
you should adopt Haskell or list or Ruby
or whatever and nobody succeeded Google
hired like the best Lisp code and the
universe only to tell him he will never
code lists for money again which is
really weird but but it makes sense it's
from their perspective it's a certain
model of doing it to add insult to
injury at some point Google added a
fourth language and it was none of the
languages that people wanted it was a
newly created language go so this is
weird right why did that happen
let's think about certain peculiar
things in the Google
model of developing and operating first
of all believe it or not Google probably
has one of the largest internal code
bases in the universe and it's all in
one repository it's the mono repo it has
become like a couple of years ago it
became a bit popular and people thought
about some companies thought about if
they should do the same but that one of
the companies that the largest codebase
is using a mono repo might be surprising
also what Google did is something we
would now call we now call it micro
services but they did micro services
before all was called micro services
that's even cooler than before or was
cool because it didn't even have a name
similar to the containers right then
months some people think micro services
implies also micro repos every micro
service has its own repo you could do it
that way some code is definitely doing
that way for better or worse but you
don't have to do it that way Google has
this mono repo approach that has a lot
of implications for one you need a very
strict style guideline for you one repo
so every single one of those three or
now four languages is really strictly
regulated you kind of have to acquire a
driver's license to even check in code
and stuff like it's quite authoritarian
plus you also restrict those languages
C++ is almost like Scala multi-paradigm
language and at Google you essentially
get told you might have learned C++ but
forget 90% of it this is the way we are
doing C++ Python its purpose better fit
to the Google development model but
still they ban it for example or
especially power features like if you
want to use matter classes because it's
cool they will tell you no it's banned
in our code base so they they have a
kind of special almost they made all
those languages DSL for the use case
then they have libraries very powerful
common libraries and all those languages
which is one of the reasons for having a
limited set of languages so you have the
same kind of libraries for all of them
for one to enable you to use the
company's infrastructure like Google
file system MapReduce whatever and also
again to keep to essentially have one
way of doing things and it's done in
that way throughout the whole company
there the c++ library has been open
sourced recently i mean the parts that
are generally applicable it's called
apps io it's kind of german was in
zurich or whatever up cell dot io it's
pretty cool to look at that and you can
learn a lot about how like google works
then purse again surprising builds are
static which in c++ is straightforward
right they statically link everything in
every binary is humongous
but that so the dependency problem java
python they don't really do it that way
but like spiritually it's done in the
same way like you have gigantic python
archives that have bundled all
dependencies the idea is you have one
giant blob you deploy somewhere and it
works this for some people appears weird
like it's backwards we have 20 years of
progress with shared libraries and now
google comes along and says no our
shared libraries also mistake from the
beginning ironically people are doing
something very similar everywhere now
they just call it containers containers
bundle all the dependencies and it's a
giant blob and you put it somewhere so
google didn't need containers for that
they had solved it by their static
builds but they needed containers a lot
for other things like resource isolation
so another irony like the reason why we
have containers on linux is not the
reason for why we all use containers now
but anyway um there's also very strong
unified tooling for like quote unquote
modern debugging diagnosis so it's all
via HTTP endpoints you can ease
the profile a binary over the network
you can do a threat um you can have
metrics you can have distributed tracing
and it's all unified everywhere there
and available in all those languages so
now let's look at go and check all those
points against it everything makes sense
now if you use go especially in the
early versions you might have been
surprised that there is no dependency
management whatsoever
why is there no dependency management
because it comes from a universe were
there there are no dependencies there's
one repository dependencies what do you
mean linked in something from somewhere
else there's no somewhere else there's
only the one repo right that's why we
have no real dependency management
building to go from the beginning then
there is this go fmt go filmed which
formats the source code for you and the
one and only way source code must be
formatted there's very strong and
powerful and strict covet and goal int
and this is all coming from Google's
authoritarian regime about coding style
it's now built into the language static
binaries ago could not dynamically link
everything in the beginning it could not
create shared libraries and people
thought what backwards stone-age but no
this is the way the the light that
Google has seen and the way to do it
from the perspective of Google fast
compile times everybody was amazed how
fast go compels but the reason was that
if you have a gigantic mono repo and if
anything changes and every second you
have multiple changes and you have to
recompile everything because you're
always built from head because that's
super agile then you want super fast
compile times ah what else the tooling
people were like traditional programmers
were disappointed that there's no
steppers that debug refer go from the
beginning but all the people who had
like done distributed programming and
and concurrent programming they were
super happy with the tooling because
they had built and profiling everything
like X
all those things that are there like
goroutine dams that are super nice this
is all coming from the tooling how
Google works and it makes a lot of sense
a step-by-step debugger in a concurrent
and distributor program doesn't make so
much sense so again now you can
understand all the good parts and deeper
of surprising or bad parts and go it's
all coming from its childhood of course
why should Google create a new language
if they have already tailored all the
other languages to that model again I
have ideas about that as an exercise you
could think which languages goes
actually replacing I mean it's not
replacing anything totally but you can
now of course I mean if we if you had an
internal view of Google we could see
what programs that are now written and
go at Google what have been written in
C++ or Python or Java before and then
you can get an idea where it was most
dearly needed that might lead to some
surprises but it's a bit of speculation
so let's do something else let's think
about the one thing that is unique here
in go and that is its concurrency model
which is CSV communicating sequential
processes that's a paradigm how to do
concurrent programming it's not a very
new thing it's an older paper this is
again a link you can click on it if you
get the slides on the website and read
about it it's kind of the it's a very
lightweight abstraction but it makes a
lot of sense and makes like modern
concurrent programming really nice and
of course you can implement this in all
languages just that in in C++ you can do
everything of course but it's it's not
built in right Java the JVM is pretty
well suited for concurrent programming
but the original Java concurrency model
it's just totally not CSP and of course
nowadays most people use Java in a
different way or they use one of the
other jvm languages Python and also like
things like Ruby they just like you can
do concurrent programming but the
runtime it's just not suited for that
that was also reason why SoundCloud
couldn't like just keep
Ruby running concurrent programming
there is like on the machine level is
really problematic anyway go head this
building
this is CSP is built into the language
primitives it's the first language that
has that so I called go a no paradigm
language now I might correct myself it
has one paradigm which is CSP or you
could say concurrent programming is so
important in modern programming
languages it's not even a paradigm
anymore it's a required feature a modern
programming language needs a sane
concurrency pattern built in and then
it's not a paradigm and goes again a new
paradigm language you might have heard
another of those go proverbs which is
the famous one don't communicate by
sharing memory share memory by
communicating that's essentially CSP
broadly simplified it's really in the
soul heart and soul of the language okay
but there is still one feature I haven't
mentioned which I think think is the
most important feature slight ghost off
because now I have to tell you a story
personal story my soundcloud story how I
came to SoundCloud I quit Google for
reasons that are also not topic of this
topics in this talk but I took my time I
investigated which company I could work
for and at some point I decided to at
least apply at SoundCloud and then they
sent you a little homework they sent
your coding challenge and I decided okay
let's solve that coding challenge but I
could do that in Python I guess I'm
pretty familiar with that but I could
also make use of the chime and learn a
new language for example go it's a shame
that I've worked for Google and never
used to go so I sat down on Friday
evening open golang.org and took the go
tour
and then started to quote a bit and I
mean yeah
Sunday evening i submitted my solution
to that challenge and a week later I had
a job I mean they also did interviews
and stuff but I literally and when I say
literally I mean literally literally I
literally learned go and wrote a
productive program in one weekend and
that I think it's the most important
feature of go and the most important
feature and a modern agile dynamic world
you have to be able to learn a language
very quickly especially in large teams
in large companies where people move
around and they have to share code a lot
and there is a price I mentioned how
powerful scholar is and NGO is sometimes
it's like it's so horribly primitive
that you could cry but you get something
back you get back that you can learn it
very quickly and you will only have like
five or six surprise moments in your
whole career and not 5,000 like in C++
[Music]
this is so important in the largely
organization get the more dynamic it
gets you you want this right you also
want this convergence on a specific
coding style and it's amazing people
join a team programming go there's never
done go before and within weeks you are
all on the same page in the way you code
this is great and now the important
inside why all those CNCs projects are
written in go I think the important
insight here that an open source project
works in that regard quite if quite
similar to an large company even worse
in a way in a large company all those
people they depend on one boss and this
boss might tell them because the boss
pays the money you have to write code in
this and that way you have to tame
voluntary workers in an open source
project and you you have even more
people and they don't even sit in the
same room they don't even know each
other they don't see each other and you
still have to converge on a certain
coding scale style all of that is super
easy visco and that's why I think it's a
very good choice for large popular
open-source project even if it might not
be technically the best choice alright
final thing goes is good for
micro-services i guess with the tooling
we have now you can totally do that
if a company approaches me and tells me
we are doing micro service most lingo
could you imagine working for us I would
say of course I could I would even like
that go for therefore clearly it's not a
systems language in the like classical
sense you should know the limits but
that's also good like go is explicit and
deliberate about its limit I like this a
lot I got really liked initially I was
totally intrigued by all those languages
that solve all your problems I had Scala
on the top of my list of languages to
learn because if you can do everything
you can do all paradigms
isn't that cool and then I realized
that's very cool for like a small team
or like for your coding in your in your
living room but it's not a good thing
for large teams and you you're actually
yeah it comes at a price
so given all of that even that it's
explicit about its limit and you have to
take them into account it's also a great
language for deference at some points we
cursed our choice when doing Prometheus
but like the bottom line is it was a
good choice and perhaps the project
wouldn't be where it is now if we had
not chosen go also all those languages I
did and I started with Fortran 77 was
pretty low go is the most addictive
language I don't know I think perhaps
this whole simplicity and yeah being
really strict about things and principle
of least surprise it gives me some kind
of peace of mind when I code it's kind
of it's then or something but anyway I
like it and I think we have three
minutes for question thank you
[Applause]
all right how does that work now
I can ask you a question if you don't
have one just raise your hand if you use
go like productively okay quite a few
all of them which is you you can just
shout it out it often works what is your
personal problem misko what do you think
is the biggest problem okay
great another one ever handling okay
cool I mean I already mentioned
dependency management that it doesn't
exist ever on the slides here because
this is next talk
I hope Christoph will like the the
teaser because these are the first two
things in its abstract now they are here
lack of generics and ven during right of
course era handling yeah it's but I
think it's the third biggest program and
that's also it will be addressed in go
to lack of generics is really
fascinating this is I mean the the code
rendering we understand now why there's
no dependency mentioned it makes sense
and it's kind of almost solved now with
go modules but we understand why it was
a problem generics is interesting
because Google always wanted generics
even in their internal thing it's just
so hard to get it right with this idea
of keeping everything simple and
principle of least surprise and there
were there were four attempts of porting
generics integral they were all rejected
and now they're for face one for go to
and it looked promising but now I
followed the discussion and it's I don't
think it will work that way it's really
a hard thing to get generics VC go
philosophy of simplicity and lead
surprise but it always works like
everybody thinks the same they're like
this is the biggest problem okay
anything else are you inspired to ask a
question now
if not should we close the session here
okay thank you very much Bjorn let's
give a big applause to Bjorn thank you
thank you
you